DOWN THE TO PLAY BOTH ENDS OF
THE FLOOR TO GET MORE MINUTES,
ESPECIALLY WITH ALL OF HIS
GO.
DEFLECTED, PASS TO CONNAUGHTON,
THEY'RE DeMAR  AWAY, DeMAR DeRO.
HIS SECOND TONIGHT.UL
REALLY EASY FOR NIKOL AGAINST J
LAND THAT TIME. NICE LOOK AWAY
FOUR ON THE SHOT CLOCK.
MOTHER, DOWN THE  --
>> Matt: JUST HUNGRY, RIGHT?
BACK NOW DRIVING.
SPINS.
LOSES IT. Alvin: GAFFORD IS A S
BLOCKER.
FRED RIGHT HERECHASED DOWN AND
COMBO. IT
HARD, LITTLE SOFTER IN IT
MIGHT HAVE BEEN
>> Hubie: GOT PLENTY OF BOSTON ,
THE BUZZER! HAT.
WHAT CAN DOE
IT'S OVER THE
NICE REBOUND TO DONNA.
LEVINE WORKINFOOLED.
HE GOES RIGHT TO THE RIM AND IS
ATHLETIC ENOUGH TO
ISH WAINWRIGHT KNOCKED DOWN A
COUPLE OF THREESTAKEOVER AT THE
ONE ARENA.
WE  THIS VIDEO OR